at a certain point either you get
frustrated or you
feel that this is never going to happen
and something better happen now because
we're not getting any younger
what does risk mean to you
I mean
I think that I mean risk is is is
having to potentially part with
something you don't want to par with
let's say
it's it's look I think that
I think a better word is gambling I
think that filmmakers especially Indie
filmmakers are they're gamblers I mean
who knows what's gonna work or not it's
a risky proposition
but we're kind of gambling are we like
are we gonna like you know perhaps
Morgan already paid off house are we
gonna like uh are we going to ask our
uncle for money do I know if I can get
that money back what's risky for him is
it risky for me it's risking that
relationship
um you know
it's it's
you have to be
I think as someone who
tries to be risk aversive like trying to
do everything I can to like to to
mitigate risk
um
there's there's only so much you can do
and at the end of the day against
gambling like you have to understand
that this money may never come back
whoever's investing your film must need
to understand that this money may never
come back hopefully you've made a good
enough script hopefully you have a
background to help Market the thing and
you're kind of you know keyed into the
business end of things or you have
somebody who's on your team who is who
can help this money come back so it's
not as much a risk but it's always there
and it's frankly always still a gamble
in this day and age there's different
ways you can get paid now and they
change from like month to month
unfortunately so you got to keep on keep
up on that too as well so it's yeah what
is risk I mean risk is fear risk can be
you know different things but ultimately
you have to be content with uh gambling
but gambling intelligently that makes
sense
how do you approach risk
I mean we try our best to mitigate
things
um you know if uh
you know for example my director did not
feel confident about one of the actors
we had hired at one point and so we said
listen we'll fly you up to wherever you
know they're shooting their show and
you'll get like you know a couple days
to work with them hopefully that can you
know take off some of the fear you have
and I don't feel that this is a risky
proposition you don't feel this is a
risky proposition anymore you can do
different things to lay people's fears
and hopefully mitigate risk
um you can't always I mean some things
you know come out of the woodwork and
you did not expect that to happen well
hopefully you're insured right that's
another way to mitigate risk
um you know hopefully you've uh paid for
all the permits and everything else
you're supposed to and it's not just
gorilla hopefully you know you've been
smart about dealing with the things in a
business-like fashion and and not
screwing over people all right I mean
there's a golden rule right doing to
others let's say right well feed your
crew feed your crew well they're working
for very little you better feed them
well and you better you know treat
everyone so well that they don't try to
turn you into some sort of a union
production if you're not Union for
example right
um these are very simple common sensical
things I think that can help mitigate
risk hopefully
and I thought it was great
about just risking a relationship if
you're asking for money you're asking
for favors or whatever that's a that's a
really good point yeah you know because
the movie May Come and Go may do well it
may not but you're risking a
relationship and you're and you're sort
of standing in that person's eyes sure
what were the risks that you took to
make one br
well
um I uh I mortgage and already paid off
house that was one thing
uh to me uh you know we had we had a
we had a we were first-time filmmakers
we were first time like you know
producers and we were first time you
know our writer writer was a first-time
writer director
um and we weren't only just risking our
money we were rest we were risking our
reputations we were risking you know uh
in some ways
maybe like our livelihoods for years to
come to try to you know pay off this
movie and the debt that would occur
um you know I think that you
anytime you make a movie you put
yourself out there you risk yourself in
a myriad of different ways like you you
risk yourself uh in a professional sense
you risk yourself in a creative sense
um the best thing you can do is surround
yourself with enough people that can
mitigate risk if you're an experienced
producer maybe you have some more
experienced producers that are guiding
guiding you and helping guide the ship
helping kind of like be your concierge
concierge or what have you that can you
know kindly get the material they
understand where you are at they
understand where this film is at now
this is what we need to do this is my
suggestion to you and you should take
their suggestion right that's something
that helps mitigate risk having
experience like on the crew whether it
be an experienced EP or first-time
director which I think is really
important or experience actors who
really can hit their marks and know
everything so you're making your days
and so forth
um these are all things that can
mitigate risk for you for the
independent filmmaker foreign
was this something you had done before
is is take out a line of credit or
something against your home no no not at
all okay
I mean in some ways it could be called
foolish in a lot of ways I had never
done it but I felt so strongly about the
project and I did feel that
um you know we came to a certain part
point in the production where
we made the movie in December 2017 we
realized we needed reshoots we couldn't
get the band back together so to speak
until September of 2018 right and we sat
and worked with David marmer we were
like okay listen
I don't care if we lose this money I
just want to make a good movie this is
our first movie this has to be good so
if we're doing reshoots let's put some
more money out there if we're doing this
that the other we'll wait until it's
good we actually made the mistake of
actually applying to festivals like
before the movie was done this is a nice
piece of advice uh never submit a film
unless it's 100 fun
because you think that the screeners can
watch with better eyes than that they
can all color correct it it's not color
correction oh it's like I can see that I
can see it'll be good they can't see it
if it'll be good I promise you they
can't uh and it's literally like you
know we got rejected from 17 different
festivals before we got accepted and the
funny thing is we got accepted from some
of the festivals that rejected Us in the
first place we're like you know you
rejected this film last year like oh we
did oh no we did it yeah you did but it
took us the second time because it was
finished right so that's that was
something that we worked with David on
WE trusted each other that's not a big
thing
um in terms of like you know things that
can do away with risk
um we trusted each other enough to
um take the time to take the time to let
it get to a place where it was good
enough and then would be accepted by
festivals and then you know then
afterwards I said well I like the like
one big Festival they got accepted by a
ton of different festivals right we had
a festival strategy if you will look we
had a list of like dream festivals we
wanted to go to and the second we got
accepted to one of them we then started
calling up the other ones Hey listen
we'd love for you to be our European
Premier our New York Premiere or
whatever it was and this was funny
because
this saves you some money instead of
actually like submitting to these
festivals you just say Hey listen we got
into this and they see a shiny thing and
they're like oh my gosh this is the new
shiny thing oh sure just send it send us
the film you don't have to like apply
you want to do anything to send us the
film and you get in if it's if they they
want it if they think it's the new shiny
thing you get in so you don't depending
like you know submission fees
so you applied to the 17 uh festivals
before the film was finished did you
have to pay submission fees you did for
a lot of them yeah yeah a lot of them I
mean sometimes you know somebody who
knows somebody and like it's your waiver
but uh by and large we submitted to them
like you know through film freeway or
whatever you do and um it was
interesting like uh you know the film
wasn't finished and we thought you know
we can't miss Sundance this year yeah
you should probably miss Sundance this
year you're never going to get in with
the unfinished work but that's the thing
a lot of times what happens with people
who make films investors want their
money back and so they're really trying
to rush you know to get this thing out
and whatever else it's not we didn't
have that Rush that was like a lucky
thing for us because we were just like
look just make it a good movie that's
the main thing
would you say sometimes the biggest risk
is not taking a risk
I mean sure like I said you can hold
yourself back I mean people hold
themselves back like it's a thing where
oh it's not the time not this year maybe
next year you know you you
definitely can be very self-defeatist I
mean people do it all the time you know
there's always an excuse oh well you
know
my kid needs braces I don't have time
for this or whatever it is there's a
myriad different reasons as to why this
could happen to you I think though at a
certain point either you get frustrated
or you
feel that this is never going to happen
and something better happen now because
we're not getting any younger that was a
big impotence for my sort of like
get off my butt and you know stop doing
this market research job and you know
let's make this movie uh was was just
that like I mean what what I mean we got
like 80 year old producer like I've
never done a movie yet I'm doing my
first one at 80. like at a certain point
you know you could but like you know if
you want to do it for a living maybe
maybe you start the switching careers
right now right so that that's uh that
that can't happen that can't happen but
I think the thing of it is you have to
talk yourself out of it and you have to
sort of really at some point
if you don't do it now when are you
going to do it
you have to ask yourself that question
yeah not to be too much of a downer but
when you see someone your own age pass
away
and it's like of natural causes or
whatever I think that's a huge
motivation however old you are I think
that you're like oh wow this thing isn't
going to go on forever sure I got to do
this now so and you talked about having
some life changes to different things so
it sounds like you were in a good space
in that sense where you're ready to try
something
and and failure wasn't too much
people in film are crazy right we're
just crazy like you know everyone you
know there's a very nomadic lifestyle to
a lot of it like like you really
literally have joined the circus and
you're going running away to the next
town and like there's that sort of
thing about filmmakers where they
they almost would do it for free
if it wasn't for bills and like family
and whatever else you'd almost do it for
free because you love it that much right
and I think that's the majority of
filmmakers who are passionate because
like God knows we're not getting paid
for it very well as far as independent
filmmakers you know like you do it for
the love of it you do it because you
know this is the one of the only things
you can see yourself doing and for a lot
of people I think that there's an idea
of having a safety net or not having a
safety net I think when you don't have a
safety net like this is all you have
you're gonna make this work you're going
to make this work like you're going to
figure out whatever problems are at you
doesn't matter because we need to make
this work because I don't have a safety
net we're gonna make this work right I
think that that that helps kind of push
you along I push you out of the nest
let's say the nest of comfortability it
helps push you out and actually fly I
guess in this analogy uh if if if either
you fly or you fall to the ground let's
say right
uh and hopefully you fly
so we're like carnies with cameras yeah
kind of I mean we're very nomadic like
you know you're going from one job to
the other job to the other job and you
know and everyone speaks the same
language she works with this like this
circus right so